hello how's it going this elevator is
like a club going up on a Tuesday
actually we're going down and such as a
little thing this your office
it's super laughs it's like watching The
Death Star
it's still out on your to boo it's just
loud everywhere I forgot my headphones
so I'm back in the elevator again I said
ed to Star web open up this isn't right
well maybe this taking you to the ground
oh geez
New York actually smells like crap right
now
it smells like horse poop do you see how
many people are in here with suits and
ties on I know where's our student ID uh
I don't know
dressed like a 1930s pilot and you're
just like a highlighter [ __ ]
just like OfficeMax the woman who
recited it back to me in a very strange
way so I hope you enjoy whatever you got
you did say coffee light though right
crap what two shots
blended six two two two two two sirs
that look right I'll push it you go get
you go get lined up
all right let's go to the secret place
let's just hop in the cab all bed so now
I'm in rehearsal for the big DGI event I
was like I even still at this point told
you guys what I've actually been doing
so I'm doing a little presentation here
and we're talking about how the Mavic is
basically going to change world of
throne there's a there's a drone in my
purse I did a few videos which you might
have already seen both of them yesterday
one of sort of like a little unboxing
but I'd have the Box yet because box
wasn't a thing yet and then I posted
another one as showing you guys kind of
a fun day that I had with Jenna so go
check those out and we're gonna do this
rehearsal I'll see you guys later
ladies and gentlemen the DJI launch
event will commence shortly we're back
and I have a lot of editing to do should
we go get food yes okay good let's do
that we're gonna go to we're gonna go
and get some food and I'm going to edit
it in dog it's really bright outside we
thought it was daylight but it's like
10:00 9:30
oh it's 9:30 for our three videos that I
have to finish editing tonight for
tomorrow and I have to get up earlier
I'm not sure this is gonna be able to
happen or not oh you know why all those
people will suit through there I just
realized like y'all know because the the
stock exchange is right somewhere over
here
I don't we should have been straight we
should have been trading I let me show
you on my PO commands so this is where
we started our day and this is where
we're gonna end it should we check it
out a picture it's really great picture
it's probably our best work I look happy
editing update it's about 1:00 a.m. I am
the kind of person that has to get sleep
or I can I don't function very well so
sometimes when you see me get a little
crazy in my videos and people are like
she's definitely on drugs I'm not I've
never done drugs before I sometimes get
headaches so like I'll get really crazy
and take an advil so unfortunately this
is me what you see is what you get every
having so much fun editing all of these
drone videos but the problem is it takes
so much time to edit and we shot so much
footage and looking for the right song
surprisingly takes a lot of time so I
think I'm going to finally go to bed
because tomorrow is a pretty big day I
somehow need to manage to go to the Lego
store tomorrow and I'm not sure if we're
gonna have time but ed and I both
brought LEGO Minifigures of ourselves so
we have to go there I'm gonna go to
sleep after this exports I probably have
another hour and then I can go to sleep
so I'll see you guys tomorrow which will
probably all be the same blog
we're back in Starbucks today is the DJI
launch day I got the same thing on that
I wore yesterday because that are the
same things that they could test the
lighting I'm tired I didn't sleep much
you never sleep nope I got three hours I
think I fell asleep maybe around three
hold up at 6:30 so I got three and a
half I don't know I tried to sleep and
then I saw there was like Star Wars
movies on so I was like uh
that's my video happening
they're about to announce it right now
[Music]
now what's so remarkable about these
images so you can fit it in almost any
bag just put it in your bag go and
create we're designing another Pro we
wanted to make it as space efficient as
possible so we actually amount the size
and weight of something that you carry
with you everyday like a bottle of water
so this is an extremely portable device
and actually this little carrying case
that helped this design for bottle of
water so persuasion anything you do on a
normal day-to-day basis and I think it's
time for us to introduce I just seen
coming to you live from somewhere within
the building I'm just seeing and I'm
pretty much the farthest thing possible
from an extreme sports athlete as you
can get what I've been doing the past 10
years is creating YouTube videos and for
me creating content about video games
technology and travel everyday life
things for me trying to find a new
perspective and a way to make those
entertaining and engaging has pretty
much been a challenge until now with the
DDI method Pro I am able to take this
thing absolutely everywhere now while it
might look like I'm hanging out the side
of the cliff
I'm not but I did get a chance to check
out the Matic pro this path to me and
now I'm going to show you
I made with me and my sister and all the
fun that we had with the drill let's
check it out CBS what we just got the DJ
automatic it's key geography chrome this
thing is so small so compact and so
amazing we can basically take it
anywhere so today we're gonna go do
ladies and gentlemen please welcome
content creator i justi christine like I
said earlier I've been making YouTube
videos past 10 years and I've seen so
many things in the past 10 years as far
as technology goes and I always love
trying to be the first one that gets a
hold of these things and see what
they're really like and for my audience
you know they're expecting you to do
cool things every day that's kind of
hard to find things that are fun
entertaining and engaging that's also
current when I'm editing and shooting
and doing it all myself so usually I'm
lugging around suitcases full of
equipment to make all of this happen but
now this is my actual purse this is what
I give it with me every day and now I am
drawing my purse like this is something
that I never really thought would be
possible and I was always intimidated by
drones for the past three years my first
started getting into them I had the DJI
phantom and then I got a phantom 4 and
now this is going to completely change
everything and I think the first step is
actually trying it and seeing how easy
it is to fly and as soon as I said
in the air I was like this is incredible
and anybody especially can play video
games holding that controller in your
hands it's basically like you're sitting
in front of your console and playing a
game but for me this is really is going
to change everything it's super simple
and trying to create and capture things
on the go is now possible especially
with the DJI Go app because you can pay
out at a picnic you can be doing the
things that do my sister did we did all
that stuff in one day and normally that
would take a few days especially with
the editing time but I can post
instantly I can stream the live on the
Internet I can be posting tweets and
everything great from the air which
before that was not impossible but now
there's no excuse because we would
always have to plan those days and we're
going to go fly a drone but now it's
basically never going to leave my purse
so for me this is definitely going to
change my life
now it'll change yours as well thank you
sip events over it was so much fun I I
know I keep talking about it but it's
seriously is so incredible you guys
haven't seen the other two videos that I
did I did a really cool hands-on demo
and I did one where I'm flying and doing
some test footage which is the video
that I showed here it was a shorter
version so you can check out the longer
version of the leaves in the description
but also I would like to introduce you
to sort of my co-host of sort he is like
a professional skier and has all these
kind of crazy shots on his youtube
channel those daily videos and we went
from like crazy drone shots of like
hiking and skiing into
me a trampoline park hello so I'd like
to introduce yourself to my YouTube
audience well I am unison and I am a
professional skier Marcus and I miss
filmer well I like to film too so we're
kind of a team and this is max hey guys
how are you this is a crazy Irish guy
that loves drones and and this guy
speaks in front of 50,000 people from
time to time so he was kind of coaching
me a little quite a few and yeah the
skater you guys absolutely nailed it
really really good well thank you the
audience for just enough yeah okay I
think it was the drone really what they
were really excited about but I think I
think it was your first if I could end
the first yeah I did it was Oliver I get
the demo
it's not out here now what my drone is
now officially smaller than our vlogging
camera I did a comparison to a bunch of
different things like it's the size of a
fork and like an iPhone like my shoe is
bigger than it I think I even like
compared it to a bag of marshmallows and
it's crazy it's so small and perfect
yeah we have so much fun yeah
so it's nice meeting you wait what's
your channel we got to tell them uh
unison yes there should be simple to
find here cool thank you okay fine we're
just talking about massages in the car
this guy try to give me a massage
whoo
oh we are going to go to the Nintendo
store have you been here recently not
recently trying to go here right now
yeah I'm ready you ready to go in yeah
I want this
that's a nice man's shirt my childhood I
had this one nice one
absolutely annihilate oh yeah you
definitely beat everybody I can't
believe I didn't give you that property
money and then I gave it to Jordan I
know I'm an idiot
um I don't have actually do I have I've
lost track guys turn I don't think I
have that actually they should become
like shopping music in here I'd spend
all my money oh my gosh look big little
baby onesies anybody have a baby that I
can buy something for multiple got more
they don't come now how would you with
just a mask instead of a backpack I'm
sure you can find a mask
okay so
I'm catching up my first Pokemon that I
caught on a Pokemon go Plus
oh it's a funny feeling it's a funny
really sir that means I call it yes so
much easier so thankfully if he gave me
a screwdrivers is always something else
is happening oh sweet baby Jesus huh we
see New York founder we need to stay
here another music well again I did was
like I thought it I didn't catch it okay
I think I'm done now this is great I'm
very happy I'm very happy with the
purchase that you told me to buy and
then you cancelled your pre-order and
told me to buy this and then the
pre-orders were gone so then I bought a
pre-order on eBay and then he end up
handling it the only thing I've ever
cancelled in my entire life and I I'm
gonna pay for it forever something's
happening
oh it tickles that it's a little too
much oh god I caught it
oh boy cata growlithe I'm over here
trying to catch a mac and white I caught
him in one press I know we need to get I
Love New York shirt except I don't think
I want to wait in the bottom line for
anything no actually I don't I don't
like New York at all but what I do love
good legal look we're here we're here it
also doesn't say I love New York so it
works out great New York the small
magnet okay he comes off it is no I
don't think it goes off it's a clue
begun so I just did something and it
felt real cool oh it feels so funny
okay you try it tell me you don't like
it here we go didn't go good until the
end full whole drawer out yeah that
feels pretty good you won't come again
you just gotta give it a good like whoa
hey I had the chance to preorder it and
then I was like no I'm not I still have
a set that I haven't built so I should
not this is not a wise adult decision of
buying this and we have I have so many
sets that we're supposed to build
together and we haven't done it well if
we get this one then we often will have
loved weight behind it
oh it looks so good Mickey's won a
tuxedo
that's it warrants the entire purchase I
can't wait to show you guys the
minifigures that we've assembled for our
New York trip the edge just seen Lego
minifigure New York versions looks great
wait bits so whatever reason they didn't
have very nice hair selections so this
is my New York version that I made I've
got a crown on
Oh guys my fig she looks a little [ __ ]
with this makeup ah I can't I can't be
seen like this I look so nice and just
sweet
and innocent
just did a really quick wardrobe change
and now we're back to where we started
today so pretty much it's been a two
days of deja vu we've done the same
thing
back-to-back and always ended up in here
yep here at Starbucks and DJ DJ I in
between I always run it together and I
say the same
like DG jizou yes chef okay cool come to
the airport
oh man the best part about being a drone
pilot and kayaking is the fact that I
didn't really paddle at all my arms are
jello
what else should we do today for no
stirring on the beach I like some the
beach you're like oh
[Music]